...
Pendant que ceux qui en ont besoin sortent et reviennent,
je vais d'abord prier pour les enfants qui vont nous quitter
pour être enseignés par notre sœur Claire pendant la prédication.
Également pour le mariage de Sème et Lana.
Je ne sais pas si ça a déjà été fait pendant que je n'étais pas là,
mais de toute façon, vous avez toujours besoin de prière,
donc je vais reprier.
Et nous allons également prier pour la prédication une nouvelle fois.
Prions ensemble.
Seigneur, nous te remercions pour les enfants que tu as donnés à notre assemblée,
aux familles de notre assemblée.
Ils sont une grâce pour leurs parents, mais pour nous tous.
Ils sont aussi une grande responsabilité.
C'est un privilège que tu leur as accordé de naître dans des familles qui te connaissent,
qui désirent te suivre et les enseigner selon ta volonté dans ta parole.
Seigneur, nous te prions que tu puisses honorer tous les efforts que les parents de notre assemblée font
dans cet enseignement de leurs enfants, dans le témoignage qu'ils veulent leur laisser aussi,
par leur attitude.
Nous te remercions pour ceux dans notre assemblée qui s'engagent dans l'enseignement des enfants,
notamment le dimanche.
et nous te prions pour que tu puisses honorer également leurs efforts
et les bénir par la présence de ton Saint-Esprit, Seigneur,
car sans toi, tout ce travail est vain et infructueux.
Nous te prions pour que les enfants puissent comprendre l'Évangile,
qu'ils puissent le chérir,
chérir ce que Jésus-Christ a accompli pour eux,
et que dès leur plus jeune âge,
ils puissent comprendre comment mettre en pratique cette foi dans leur vie.
Nous te remercions pour le mariage de Sème et Lana.
Nous te prions de les bénir dans leur couple,
aussi avec des enfants, Seigneur,
qu'ils puissent rester fidèles premièrement envers toi,
fidèles l'un envers l'autre,
et qu'ils puissent avoir un bon témoignage
au sein de notre communauté dans leur mariage.
Enfin, Seigneur, nous nous approchons de ta parole,
sans laquelle il ne peut y avoir de vie en nous,
sans laquelle nous sommes livrés à la folie de notre chair,
de notre entendement corrompu par le péché.
Nous te prions, Seigneur,
pour que ce qui sera planté ce matin dans nos cœurs
puisse fructifier par l'œuvre de ton Saint-Esprit,
pour le bien de chaque personne qui entendra cette prédication,
pour le bien de ton Église et pour ta gloire.
Nous prions au nom de Jésus-Christ. Amen.
Nous allons continuer ce matin l'étude de l'épître de Jacques.
Vous pouvez ouvrir cet épître avec moi au premier chapitre.
Nous allons reprendre là où nous l'avions laissé,
c'est-à-dire à partir du verset 16 jusqu'au verset 18 ce matin,
en concluant ce qui peut être considéré comme l'introduction de cette lettre,
avec, vous le verrez, l'exposition d'une des doctrines les plus essentielles,
les plus glorieuses de notre foi chrétienne.
Nous allons lire maintenant ce passage.
Jacques 1, 16 à 18.
Ne vous y trompez pas, mes frères bien-aimés,
toute grâce excellente et tout don parfait descendent d'en haut,
du Père des Lumières,
chez lequel il n'y a ni changement ni ombre de variation.
Il nous a engendrés selon sa volonté,
par la parole de vérité,
afin que nous soyons en quelque sorte les prémices de ses créatures.
Amen.
Il est important de nous rappeler,
avant de nous plonger dans ces versets que nous venons de lire,
quel est l'objectif principal de Jacques à travers sa lettre.
Son objectif, c'est d'encourager vivement le troupeau du Seigneur que nous sommes,
et que toutes les églises locales composent,
à mettre en pratique sa foi dans tous les domaines de notre vie.
Jacques est un pasteur, nous ne devons pas l'oublier,
cette lettre est une lettre pastorale,
c'est un des premiers pasteurs de la jeune église du Nouveau Testament.
Il a côtoyé son demi-frère qui n'est autre que Jésus-Christ,
tout au long de son ministère terrestre,
et les enseignements de Jacques ressemblent beaucoup d'ailleurs
à ceux de notre Seigneur, ce qui n'est pas étonnant.
Malgré l'importance évidente que Jacques accorde dans sa lettre
à la pratique de la foi,
aux œuvres chrétiennes,
et contrairement à ce qu'on peut entendre parfois,
Jacques est tout à fait clair sur le fait que nous ne sommes absolument pas sauvés
par la quantité ou même la qualité de nos œuvres,
mais uniquement par le moyen de la foi
qui nous unit au Christ
et qui nous revêt de la justice du Christ.
Mais il est vrai que Jacques est aussi très clair
sur le fait que cette foi salvatrice,
cette foi unique, ne peut être qu'une foi vivante
qui, tout comme un arbre qui est planté près d'un courant d'eau,
porte nécessairement du fruit de l'esprit.
C'est-à-dire que si un homme affirme
que Jésus est le Messie,
si cet homme affirme
qu'il est uni au Christ par la foi
et que le Christ vit en lui par le Saint-Esprit,
mais que cet homme ne manifeste pas le fruit de l'esprit dans sa vie,
il n'est rien d'autre qu'un menteur,
il n'est rien d'autre qu'un imposteur.
C'est une vérité que l'apôtre Jean exprime aussi très bien
dans sa propre lettre
avec des mots très proches de ceux de Jacques.
Nous pouvons lire ce passage en 1 Jean 1, versets 5 à 8.
La nouvelle que nous avons apprise de lui,
c'est-à-dire de Christ,
et que nous vous annonçons,
c'est que Dieu est lumière
et qu'il n'y a point en lui de ténèbres.
Si nous disons que nous sommes en communion avec lui
et que nous marchions dans les ténèbres,
nous mentons
et nous ne pratiquons pas la vérité.
Mais si nous marchons dans la lumière
comme il est lui-même dans la lumière,
nous sommes mutuellement en communion
et le sang de Jésus son Fils
nous purifie de tout péché.
Les œuvres d'un homme ne sont que le résultat,
l'expression,
le témoignage de sa vie intérieure,
de l'état spirituel de son âme.
C'est ce que nous avons vu
dans la précédente prédication,
notamment des versets 13 à 15.
Nous avons vu
quels fruits mauvais la nature humaine
produit dès notre naissance.
De mauvais désirs
qui engendrent le péché,
qui finit par engendrer la mort.
Le péché qui a pour finalité
la mort éternelle,
ce n'est que le résultat,
l'expression,
le témoignage public
de la mort spirituelle de notre âme.
Une racine pourrie donnera
un arbre mauvais
qui produira de mauvais fruits
ou pas de fruits du tout.
Et le maraîcher finit toujours
par se débarrasser d'un tel arbre.
Ce que nous avons vu la dernière fois,
c'est que même chez le chrétien,
il y a un reste
de cette nature corrompue.
C'est cette nature corrompue
qui continue malheureusement
de générer en nous
de mauvais désirs.
des désirs mauvais
qui nous attirent
comme des appâts.
C'est la métaphore
que Jacques utilise
dans ses versets.
Ces mauvais désirs
qui nous poussent
vers le piège du péché
qui, lorsqu'il se referme sur nous,
nous tue.
Non seulement ce reste de corruption
nous attire vers le péché,
mais il nous pousse en plus
à accuser Dieu,
à accuser sa providence
ou à accuser les autres
qui nous entourent
d'être responsables
de notre propre péché.
En particulier lorsque
nous sommes éprouvés
et que nous chutons
dans l'épreuve.
Nous sommes pronts
à cause de la corruption
de notre chair
à accuser Dieu
ou les autres.
Et nous avons vu
que tout l'argumentaire
de Jacques
a pour but
de nous faire réaliser,
de nous faire avouer,
reconnaître
que peu importe
les circonstances
de nos vies,
nous sommes les seuls
responsables de notre péché
devant Dieu
et devant les hommes.
Nous péchons
car le reste de corruption
dans notre chair
aime le péché
et nous attire vers lui.
Pour nous convaincre
que nous sommes
les seuls responsables
de notre péché,
Jacques met donc
l'emphase
dans les versets 13 à 15
sur la sainteté,
la pureté,
la perfection morale
de Dieu
afin de nous montrer
qu'il est impossible
que Dieu soit tenté
par le mal,
qu'il pratique le mal
et donc qu'il pousse
quiconque vers le mal.
et Jacques met ensuite
l'emphase
par contraste
sur notre corruption,
nos mauvais désirs,
notre péché,
notre mort spirituelle
afin de nous faire réaliser
que le mal
vient de nous,
qu'il est produit
par notre cœur corrompu,
que la source
de notre souillure
est en nous
et non en dehors de nous,
que ce qui nous souille,
ce n'est pas ce qui entre
en nous
mais ce qui sort de nous.
Nous portons
dans notre chair
la mort
à cause
de notre péché.
Nous nous étions
arrêtés sur ce point
la dernière fois
parce qu'il y avait
largement
de quoi méditer
avec ces versets
mais pour autant
comme nous allons le voir
Jacques poursuit
dans les versets 16 à 18
le raisonnement
qu'il a commencé
au verset 12.
Il poursuit sa réflexion
en reprenant
dans ces versets
le même schéma
c'est-à-dire
en partant
de la nature de Dieu
avant de revenir
à notre nature
à nous
les êtres humains
pour en tirer
des conclusions
sur nous-mêmes.
Mais alors qu'au verset 13 et 15
il met l'emphase
comme nous l'avons vu
sur notre chair naturelle
cette chair corrompue
par le péché
et sur les conséquences
de cette corruption
dans les versets 16 à 18
il met cette fois-ci
l'emphase
sur l'une des doctrines
les plus importantes
et glorieuses
comme je le disais
des écritures
notre nouvelle naissance
notre régénération
notre nouvelle nature
inclinée cette fois-ci
non plus vers le mal
mais vers le bien.
Il ne s'agit plus
dans ces versets
de voir ce que Dieu
ne peut pas faire
mais ce que Dieu fait.
Il ne s'agit plus
de considérer
ce que nous devrions
arrêter
de faire
en tant que chrétiens
mais ce que nous
devrions faire.
Car vous le savez maintenant
après que David
notre pasteur
la main de foi répétée
dans ses prédications
sur les dix commandements
lorsque Dieu interdit
une chose
il leur donne
en même temps
l'inverse.
La vie chrétienne
ce n'est pas seulement
ne plus faire le mal
ne plus pécher
c'est aussi être saint
c'est travailler activement
à notre sanctification
pratiquer les œuvres
de justice
que Dieu
a préparé d'avance
pour nous
dans ce but
que nous les pratiquions.
Dans les versets 12 à 15
nous avons vu
ce que nous ne devons pas faire
en tant que chrétiens
ce que nous devons combattre
de toutes nos forces
c'est-à-dire
notre chair
notre ancienne nature
le vieil homme
comme la parole
le désigne parfois.
Nous devons asphyxier
nous devons tuer
ces mauvais désirs
qui émanent encore
de nos cœurs mauvais
afin qu'ils ne se transforment
pas en péché
en péché consommé
qui nous mènerait
à la mort.
Aujourd'hui
dans les versets 16 à 18
nous allons voir l'inverse
ce que nous devons faire
en tant que chrétiens
ce que nous devons travailler
à faire croître en nous
de toutes nos forces
cette nouvelle nature
cet homme
cette femme
cet enfant
né de nouveau
que nous sommes
par la grâce
et la toute puissance
de Dieu.
Le verset 18
est une magnifique exposition
de la doctrine chrétienne
de la régénération.
que l'on appelle aussi
la nouvelle naissance
qui comme je le disais
est une des doctrines
les plus fondamentales
de notre foi chrétienne
et il n'est pas étonnant
que Jacques conclue
l'introduction de sa lettre
par cette vérité
si essentielle
pour bien comprendre
tout ce qu'il dira
par la suite.
Mais cette doctrine fondamentale
a elle-même
une fondation
qui nous est présentée
au verset 17
et qui est comme au verset 13
ni plus ni moins
que Dieu lui-même
sa nature
ses attributs
c'est encore une fois
une fois n'est pas coutume
par la contemplation
de la nature de Dieu
que nous devons commencer
car c'est uniquement
de cette manière
que nous pourrons atteindre
le but de cette prédication
qui est
de contempler
la beauté
de notre régénération
dans son origine
dans son moyen
et dans son but.
ce seront nos trois parties
pour ce matin.
Nous allons donc
contempler ensemble
cette merveilleuse doctrine
et je profite
de cette occasion
pour encourager
ceux d'entre nous
qui ressentiraient
à certains moments
de leur vie
une lassitude
une accoutumance
voire une indifférence
face aux vérités bibliques
telles que celle-ci
je peux vous assurer
et je me prends
comme exemple
que cela peut arriver
lorsque vous passez
plusieurs années
à lire
à écouter
à étudier
la théologie
notamment la théologie
réformée
que vous finissez
par devenir
tellement habitués
à certains termes
à certaines définitions
que vous êtes
d'une certaine manière
fatigué
de les réentendre
encore et encore.
Et bien la parole
de Dieu a cela
de merveilleux
que même après
toutes ces années
le Saint-Esprit
renouvelle en nous
l'émerveillement
et l'adoration
face à une vérité
si glorieuse
que celle
de notre nouvelle naissance.
Et c'est ma prière
pour nous tous
ce matin
que par la grâce
de Dieu
nous puissions
tous tomber
en adoration
devant ce don
devant cette grâce
si merveilleuse
que Dieu nous a accordée.
Et c'est justement
par la considération
des dons
des grâces divines
que nous allons
commencer cette méditation
à partir du verset 16
car comme je le disais
nous ne pouvons pas
comprendre l'origine
le moyen
ni le but
de cette nouvelle naissance
si nous ne comprenons
pas d'abord
qui Dieu est.
Jacques nous a déjà
montré au verset 13
qu'absolument
rien de mauvais
ne peut sortir
de Dieu.
Et par effet de contraste
il affirme maintenant
au verset 17
non seulement
que tout ce qui vient
de Dieu est bon
puisque rien de mauvais
ne peut sortir de Dieu
mais qu'absolument
tout ce qui est bon
dans la création
vient de Dieu.
il n'y a pas
d'autre source
de bonté
dans la création
que Dieu lui-même.
Cette réalité
vaut la peine
qu'on s'y arrête
un instant
parce qu'elle est
évidemment
une source
presque inépuisable
d'adoration
et d'action de grâce
envers notre Seigneur.
Et permettez-moi
de commencer
par une courte parenthèse
en faisant
de ces versets
une application
pour ce que nous avons
considéré la fois dernière
sur la facilité
malheureuse
que nous avons
à nous plaindre
et à accuser Dieu
lorsque nous sommes
dans l'épreuve.
Ne sommes-nous pas
si pronts
à prendre pour acquis
tant de choses
dans nos vies
qui sont en fait
des grâces exceptionnelles,
des grâces excellentes,
des dons parfaits
que Dieu nous accorde ?
Réalisons-nous
que non seulement
Dieu ne nous pousse
jamais au mal
mais qu'en plus
c'est de sa main
que nous vient
absolument tout
ce qui est bon
dans notre vie
et dans celle
de chaque être humain.
Mes yeux
qui s'ouvrent le matin
et qui peuvent
contempler la création.
Mon épouse
à mes côtés,
mes enfants
qui jouent dans leur chambre,
ce corps
qui peut se lever
et s'engager
dans tellement d'activités
variées et agréables,
cet esprit
qui est capable
de concevoir
des pensées complexes,
d'entretenir
des relations,
des amitiés
avec d'autres personnes
pendant une vie entière,
ces émotions
qui secouent mon corps,
le plaisir
de manger,
d'écouter de la musique,
de courir,
de rire,
de dormir
et de voir un jour
donner suite
à un autre jour.
Et pour nous,
chrétiens,
même si on nous retire
toutes ces choses,
nous conservons
ces pensées
et ces affections
qui nous unissent
au Christ,
ce plaisir
que nous trouvons
dans sa parole,
dans la joie
de notre salut.
En réalité,
la liste
des bienfaits divins
dans notre vie
est infinie.
Et le fait
de considérer
qu'aucune tentation
ne peut venir de Dieu
car il est infiniment
et parfaitement bon
n'est pas le seul remède
contre le fait
de murmurer contre lui
lorsqu'il nous éprouve,
comme nous l'avons vu
la dernière fois.
Nous devons également
prendre la bonne habitude
de compter
les bienfaits de Dieu.
Comme le dit ce chant
qu'on entonne souvent
au début des agapes.
Je lis en ce moment
un petit livre
du puritain John Flavel
qui s'intitule
« Faire face au deuil ».
Et l'un des conseils
qu'il donne dans ce livre
aux chrétiens
qui font face
à la perte
d'un être cher,
c'est de remercier Dieu
pour toutes les grâces
qu'il leur conserve
malgré cette perte.
Quelles que soient
les circonstances
que nous traversons,
quel que soit
le deuil
qui nous accable,
nous aurons toujours
des grâces de Dieu
dans cette vie
et dans celle à venir
pour lesquelles
nous pouvons
lui être reconnaissants.
Nous n'avons
aucune raison
de murmurer
contre Dieu
mais à l'inverse,
nous avons de multiples
raisons
de le louer
car toute grâce
excellente,
tout don parfait
que nous expérimentons
dans notre vie
nous viennent de lui.
Dieu
n'est que bonté
et il manifeste
sa bonté aux hommes
de tant de manières
différentes
que nous ne pouvons
les compter.
et nous devons
vraiment combattre
cette mauvaise habitude
que nous avons
de considérer
beaucoup de choses
dans nos vies
de manière triviale.
Particulièrement
tant que chrétien,
nous devons honorer
notre Père Céleste
en exprimant
par nos mots,
par nos attitudes
qu'effectivement,
tout ce qu'il y a
de bon dans nos vies
est une grâce
excellente,
un don
parfait
de Dieu.
Ne disons pas
par chance
mais grâce à Dieu.
Ne disons pas
c'est normal
mais loué soit Dieu.
Rien n'est trivial,
rien n'est commun,
rien n'est acquis
dans notre vie.
Mais toute grâce
excellente
et tout don parfait
viennent d'en haut
et descendent
du Père des Lumières.
La raison
pour laquelle
rien de mauvais
ne peut venir de Dieu
nous est présentée
dans la deuxième partie
du verset 17.
Il est
le Père
des Lumières.
Peut-être
les avez-vous vus
pour ceux
qui s'intéressent
à la conquête spatiale
ou à l'observation
de l'espace.
Récemment
ont été publiés
des clichés
du télescope Hubble
qui est capable
de voir très loin
dans notre univers.
Et sur certaines
de ces photos
il nous est dit
qu'on peut même
on pourrait contempler
les limites
ce qui serait
de notre univers.
Certaines
de ces images
sont vertigètes
elles sont vraiment
à couper le souffle
on peut y voir
des astres
immenses
d'un éclat aveuglant
avec des couleurs
vraiment fantastiques.
Eh bien
prenez tous
ces astres éclatants
additionnez-les
ensemble
et ils seraient
comme un trou noir
face à l'éclat
de la gloire
de Dieu.
Notre Dieu
est le Père
des Lumières
c'est lui
qui a créé
ces astres glorieux.
Il est l'astre
des astres
il est plus brûlant
plus éclatant
que des milliers
de soleils
réunis
et entre une telle
lumière et l'ombre
il ne peut y avoir
de cohabitation.
Il n'y a rien
de plus mutuellement
exclusif
que l'ombre
et la lumière.
L'un chasse
nécessairement
l'autre
aucune cohabitation
n'est possible.
Notez bien
cette phrase
parce qu'elle sera
la colonne vertébrale
de cette prédication.
entre la lumière
éclatante
de la sainteté
de Dieu
et les ténèbres
de nos cœurs
il ne peut y avoir
de cohabitation.
Entre la lumière
éclatante
de la sainteté
divine
et les ténèbres
de nos cœurs
il ne peut y avoir
de cohabitation.
Comme l'a dit
une fois Paul Washer
voulez-vous connaître
la pire nouvelle
que l'humanité
ait reçu ?
Dieu est saint
Le plus grand péril
de l'humanité
chers amis
ce n'est pas
le réchauffement climatique
la crise économique
le capitalisme
le communisme
le wokisme
ou tout autre isme
le plus grand péril
de l'humanité
c'est la sainteté
de Dieu.
Pourquoi pourrait-on dire
n'est-ce pas
une bonne chose
a priori
d'être pur
d'être saint ?
Si bien sûr
le problème
ce n'est pas
que Dieu est saint
le problème
c'est que nous
ne le sommes pas.
Voilà depuis
que Adam et Ève
se rangèrent
du côté
du diable
contre Dieu
leur créateur
le problème
insoluble
de l'humanité
Dieu est saint
et nous ne le sommes pas
nous ne le sommes plus
Adam et Ève
ont été chassés
et condamnés
à mourir
hors du jardin d'Éden
hors du temple
hors de la maison
de Dieu
à cause de cette corruption
qui est entrée en eux
et qu'ils nous ont
transmise à tous
donc depuis ce jour
de la chute
l'humanité
est sous la malédiction
du péché originel
dans lequel nous sommes
tous conçus
dans lequel nous naissons tous
et qui condamne
qui nous condamne
à être éternellement
séparés de Dieu
par la mort perpétuelle
en enfer
alors certains pourraient dire
et bien
si Dieu et nous
sommes si incompatibles
que ça
il n'a qu'à vivre
de son côté
et nous du nôtre
mais c'est impossible
car Dieu est esprit
Dieu est infini
Dieu est omniprésent
et aucun espace
de sa création
n'est indépendant
de sa sainteté
il n'y a pas de sas
d'indépendance
de décompression
dans lequel nous pourrions
nous cacher
de la sainteté de Dieu
on pourrait dire alors
et bien
Dieu n'a qu'à s'adapter
il n'a qu'à changer
pour que lui et nous
nous devenions compatibles
mais c'est impossible
car Jacques nous dit
au verset 17
qu'il n'y a en Dieu
point de variation
ni aucun ombre
de changement
Dieu est
et sera à jamais
le père des lumières
le Dieu
trois fois saint
car il est immuable
il ne change pas
on pourrait encore dire
pourtant ça a l'air
de marcher
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
Dieu est dans son ciel
et nous tranquilles
sur terre
on n'a qu'à
en rester là
c'est vrai que pour le moment
on pourrait se dire
que ça fonctionne
mais ce n'est que
parce que Dieu
use de patience
et retarde
son jugement
pour que tous
ses élus
soient sauvés
et ne nous y trompons pas
chaque jour
qui passe
nous rapproche
de ce jugement
final et éternel
parce que Dieu
n'est pas seulement saint
il est aussi juste
et il ne peut
laisser impunis
tous les péchés
que nous commettons
chaque jour
envers lui
et envers nos semblables
bref pour le dire
plus simplement
nous sommes
séparés de Dieu
par un ravin
sans fond
qui a la forme
de notre péché
nous sommes privés
de toute communion
avec Dieu
car il est pure lumière
et que nous sommes
purs ténèbres
et comme rien
ne peut ternir sa lumière
qu'elle est omniprésente
et éternelle
il n'y a que deux solutions
pour nous
les êtres humains
soit nous restons ombre
et nous serons
consumés par l'éclat
de la lumière divine
soit nous devenons
nous aussi lumière
et nous participerons
alors à son éclat
voici les deux
seuls destins possibles
pour l'être humain
être consumé
par l'éclat
de la sainteté de Dieu
ou participer
à cet éclat
ne vous laissez pas tromper
par les fausses représentations
de l'enfer
l'enfer ce n'est pas
le paradis des pécheurs
aucun pécheur
n'expérimentera
la moindre once
de plaisir
et de soulagement
en enfer
encore moins d'indépendance
vis-à-vis de Dieu
comme
ils peuvent encore
en avoir l'illusion
aujourd'hui sur terre
tous les hommes
passeront l'éternité
dans la présence de Dieu
la seule différence
c'est que les uns
y brûleront perpétuellement
et les autres
y brilleront perpétuellement
le paradis
c'est la présence
bienveillante
de la gloire de Dieu
l'enfer
c'est la présence
ravageuse
de la gloire
de Dieu
pour ceux qui seraient
toujours intéressés
par l'enfer
la solution est simple
ne changez rien
continuez à vivre
comme vous l'entendez
sans vous soucier
de la volonté de Dieu
et de son évangile
vous êtes de toute façon
déjà jugé
vous êtes déjà condamné
depuis votre naissance
et chaque jour
vous marchez volontairement
plus loin
en enfer
vous creusez
votre propre tombe
toujours plus profondément
voilà la situation
de tout homme
qui continue
de tourner le dos
à Dieu
pour ceux qui seraient
intéressés par le paradis
la solution
est beaucoup moins simple
puisque à vous
cela est impossible
vous ne pouvez absolument
rien faire
pour conjurer
cette malédiction
du jugement
de la mort éternelle
qui pèse sur vous
vous ne pouvez rien faire
pour vous purifier
suffisamment
pour que votre éclat
soit compatible
avec celui
de la sainteté
de Dieu
vous n'y pouvez rien
car cette corruption
cette souillure
du péché
elle est gravée
dans votre chair
elle fait partie
de votre être
il ne s'agit pas seulement
de quelques actes
mauvais isolés
mais de notre nature
qui est mauvaise
et donc pour être débarrassé
de cette nature mauvaise
il faudrait que vous soyez
d'une essence différente
à la fois toujours vous-même
puisqu'on parle de vous
mais à la fois aussi
quelqu'un d'autre
quelqu'un qui soit né
sans cette corruption
du péché
autrement dit
pour que nous puissions
vivre dans la présence
de Dieu
sans être consumés
par sa gloire
il faudrait que nous naissions
une nouvelle fois
cette fois-ci
pure et sans tâche
et que nous recevions
une nouvelle nature
sainte
et que l'ancienne
disparaisse
c'est parce que Dieu
est saint par nature
et que nous sommes
pécheurs par nature
que nous devons naître
de nouveau
si nous voulons vivre
dans sa présence
sa présence bienveillante
sans cette nouvelle naissance
sans cette nouvelle nature
pure et incorruptible
aucun de nous
n'entrera au paradis
ne pourra se tenir
dans la présence
de Dieu
voilà pourquoi
la régénération
est nécessaire
pour tout homme
qui souhaite
retrouver cette intimité
perdue
avec Dieu
au paradis
maintenant que nous avons
établi la nécessité
de cette nouvelle naissance
nous allons considérer
sa beauté
car en effet
ce n'est pas seulement
un acte nécessaire
pour notre salut
c'est aussi un acte
d'une grande beauté
qui mérite
notre contemplation
et pour comprendre
et apprécier
cette beauté
nous devons comprendre
comment cette nouvelle naissance
d'un homme s'opère
comment peut-on naître
de nouveau
après ce que nous venons
de considérer
cela devrait être
la question
la plus importante
la plus cruciale
de notre vie
comment puis-je naître
une nouvelle fois
et obtenir cette nouvelle nature
compatible
avec la sainteté
de Dieu
cette question
nous ne sommes pas
les premiers
à nous la poser
un éminent docteur
de la loi
Nicodème
l'a posé à Jésus
dans la distrétion
d'une nuit
à Jérusalem
en ces termes
que nous pouvons lire
en Jean 3
verset 4
comment un homme
peut-il naître
quand il est vieux
peut-il entrer
dans le sein
de sa mère
et naître
question à la fois logique
pour un homme
mais aussi naïve
venant d'un docteur
d'Israël
comme d'ailleurs
lui reprochera Jésus
un peu plus loin
dans leur discussion
mais Jésus répond
à sa question
de cette manière
au verset 5
en vérité
je te le dis
si un homme
ne naît d'eau
et d'esprit
il ne peut entrer
dans le royaume
de Dieu
ce qui est né
de la chair
est chair
et ce qui est né
de l'esprit
est esprit
ne t'autant pas
que je t'ai dit
il faut que vous
naissiez de nouveau
le vent souffle
où il veut
et tu entends
le bruit
mais tu ne sais pas
d'où il vient
ni où il va
il en est ainsi
de tout homme
qui est né
de l'esprit
Jésus nous donne
des informations
très claires
et importantes
dans ce passage
sur notre nouvelle naissance
premièrement
contrairement
à notre première naissance
qui est physique
puisque nous sommes
nés de la chair
cette seconde naissance
est spirituelle
nous naissons
de l'esprit
deuxièmement
cette nouvelle naissance
!
est nécessaire
pour entrer au paradis
comme nous l'avons vu
elle est nécessaire
et troisièmement
et c'est un point
tout à fait important
de la même manière
qu'aucun nouveau-né
n'a décidé
et joué un rôle
dans sa propre conception
et mise au monde
aucun être humain
n'a décidé
et joué un rôle
dans sa propre
nouvelle naissance
la nouvelle naissance
ou régénération
qui veut dire littéralement
recréation
renaissance
est un acte
monergiste
du Dieu trinitaire
c'est-à-dire
un acte
qui dépend
uniquement
de Dieu
et de personne d'autre
seul Dieu
est à l'oeuvre
dans notre régénération
nous devons avoir conscience
qu'aucune métaphore
n'est utilisée
au hasard
par Dieu
dans sa parole
si Dieu qualifie
le seul processus
qui peut nous permettre
d'être à nouveau
en communion
avec lui
de nouvelle naissance
c'est bien
que nous devons
devenir quelqu'un
de substantiellement nouveau
et que nous ne pouvons
pas accomplir
ce changement
nous-mêmes
nous devons être
engendrés
par quelqu'un d'autre
tout comme un enfant
est conçu
et engendré
par ses parents
et non
par lui-même
c'est exactement
ce que dit Jacques
au verset 18
il
c'est-à-dire
Dieu
nous a engendré
de sa pure
volonté
arrêtons-nous
un instant
sur ces mots
frères et sœurs
et revenons un peu
en arrière
nous avons vu
que Dieu
est parfaitement pur
trois fois saint
que de lui
ne sort que grâce
excellente
et donc parfait
nous avons vu
que nous sommes
entièrement corrompus
dans notre chair
vendus au péché
dès notre naissance
et justement
séparés de Dieu
condamnés à la mort éternelle
à cause de ce péché
que nous aimons
Dieu est lumière
nous sommes ténèbres
nous sommes
substantiellement opposés
mutuellement exclusifs
essentiellement
incompatibles
Dieu ne peut supporter
notre présence
et nous ne pouvons
survivre
en la sienne
nous sommes donc
justement condamnés
à vivre
hors de sa maison
hors des murs
de sa cité céleste
dans le chaos
et la mort éternelle
et c'est alors
qu'interviennent
les deux mots
les plus
beaux et surprenants
de la Bible
mais Dieu
considérant
cet état
que nous venons
de décrire
de sa pure
volonté
nous dit Jacques
c'est à dire
sans aucune
aucune sollicitation
ou motivation
extérieure
à Dieu lui-même
a décidé
qu'au lieu
de nous détruire
éternellement
il nous ferait
vivre
éternellement
et pour que cela
soit possible
il a décidé
encore une fois
par le seul
élan de son amour
de sa miséricorde
envers nous
de faire de nous
ses propres enfants
en devenant
notre père
parmi toutes
les grâces
excellentes
et tous les dons
parfaits
dont Dieu
nous comble
chaque jour
le don de la
régénération
les surpasse
tous
en gloire
et en beauté
nous étions
livrés
à nous-mêmes
nous courions
de toutes nos forces
vers les profondeurs
de l'enfer
dans lesquelles
nous sommes nés
et auxquelles
nous appartenions
mais Dieu
notre créateur
plutôt que
de nous laisser là
a décidé
selon sa pure
volonté
de nous
recréer
une seconde fois
en nous donnant
une nature
nouvelle
compatible
avec la sienne
afin que nous
puissions à nouveau
jouir de la joie
profonde et éternelle
que seule sa présence
favorable
peut apporter
à notre âme
et à notre être
tout entier
voilà un premier point
qui nous aide à considérer
la beauté
de la régénération
Dieu
à lui seul
a décidé
de se faire
notre père
de nous engendrer
spirituellement
afin de nous rendre
participants
de sa propre nature
divine
comme le dit
l'apôtre Pierre
afin que nous puissions
à nouveau
nous asseoir
à ses côtés
dans l'intimité
de sa maison
le père
des lumières
a décidé
de transformer
nos ténèbres
en sa lumière
en la faisant
habiter en nous
afin que nous
participions
à l'éclat
de sa gloire
pour les siècles
des siècles
n'est-ce pas glorieux ?
est-ce que cela
ne nous pousse pas
naturellement
à l'adoration ?
et permettez-moi
cette courte parenthèse
mais comment
en lisant ce texte
et bien d'autres
dans les écritures
pouvons-nous considérer
que nous participons
d'une quelconque manière
à notre nouvelle naissance ?
lorsque la Bible
nous décrit
comme mort
spirituellement
sans vie
et dans le besoin
de naître
de nouveau
à part en ne tenant
pas compte
de ces termes
et donc en accusant
par là
le Saint-Esprit
de négligence
dans le choix
de ces mots
comment pouvons-nous
ne pas reconnaître
que notre régénération
est un acte
entièrement décidé
et accompli
par Dieu
selon sa pure volonté
par amour
par miséricorde
par grâce
seul un fou
affirmerait
qu'il a participé
à sa conception
et à sa naissance
et seul un fou
j'ose le dire ce matin
affirmera
qu'il a participé
à sa régénération
la Bible dit
que nous sommes
morts spirituellement
dès notre naissance
qui a déjà vu un mort
participer à sa résurrection
qui a déjà vu
un nouveau-né
participer à sa conception
alors qu'il n'existait
même pas
mais la réalité
de l'être humain
est encore pire
que la passivité
d'un nouveau-né
ou d'un mort
parce que nous ne sommes
pas immobiles
en attendant simplement
qu'on vienne nous sauver
nous ressusciter
nous régénérer
nous sommes encore moins
comme ces illustrations
qu'on peut voir parfois
où une main sort de l'eau
et cherche à attraper
celle que Dieu lui tend
non
frères et sœurs
la mort spirituelle
de l'être humain
elle n'est pas passive
elle est terriblement active
mais dans le mauvais sens
avant que Dieu
ne nous régénère
nous n'étions pas inertes
et nous cherchions
encore moins
l'aide de Dieu
nous nagions
de toutes nos forces
dans les sombres profondeurs
afin d'être recouverts
par ces ténèbres
que nous aimions tant
pour nous cacher
de la lumière de Dieu
dans sa mort spirituelle
l'être humain naturel
fait tout pour fuir Dieu
pour fuir la vérité
pour fuir la lumière
qui met en évidence
son péché
en préférant
se cacher
dans les ténèbres
qui camouflent
l'horreur
de son péché
c'est pourquoi
il est aberrant
de penser
que l'homme participe
à son salut
en choisissant
de suivre Jésus
aucun de nous
ne peut devenir
disciple du Christ
si le Père des Lumières
ne le fait d'abord
naître de nouveau
selon sa pure volonté
ainsi que l'enseigne
d'ailleurs
puisque les passages
sont nombreux
de toute manière
Jésus Christ
en ces termes
nul ne peut venir à moi
si le Père
qui m'a envoyé
ne l'attire
et je le ressusciterai
au dernier jour
Jean 6, 44
pourtant malgré
toutes ces évidences
bibliques
beaucoup de chrétiens
en disant
que ce sont eux
qui ont choisi
de suivre Jésus
affirment
qu'ils sont à l'origine
ou au moins
qu'ils ont participé
à leur propre
nouvelle naissance
c'est non seulement
une aberration
selon la nature
comme nous l'avons vu
selon les écritures
mais c'est aussi
se priver
d'une grande
et belle source
d'adoration
envers notre Père Céleste
comme le dit Flavel
dans son livre
sur le deuil
lorsque Dieu
nous reprend
ce qu'il nous a donné
nous devrions
plutôt être étonnés
émus
et poussés
à la reconnaissance
face à toutes les grâces
qu'il nous conserve
et si cette perspective
est vraie pour tous
les dons de Dieu
elle l'est aussi
pour la grâce excellente
le don parfait
de la régénération
nous ne devrions pas
nous étonner
voire nous énerver
devant le fait
que Dieu ne sauve pas
tous les êtres humains
nous devrions
plutôt être étonnés
émerveillés
et reconnaissants
que Dieu décide
d'en sauver
ne serait-ce qu'un seul
car il ne doit rien
à l'être humain
mis à part
son juste jugement
gloire soit rendue
à Dieu
qui accorde
la grâce excellente
de la régénération
selon sa pure volonté
mais la beauté
de notre régénération
ne réside pas uniquement
dans la volonté de Dieu
qui est son origine
elle se trouve aussi
dans le moyen
que Dieu utilise
pour nous faire naître
de nouveau
jusqu'ici
nous avons contemplé
le principe
de notre nouvelle naissance
nous comprenons
que notre nature
doit changer
pour être conforme
à celle de Dieu
afin de ne pas être
consumé dans sa présence
mais Dieu utilise
un moyen précis
pour que nous naissions
de nouveau spirituellement
la suite du verset 18
nous dit
il nous a engendré
de sa pure volonté
par la parole
de la vérité
qu'est-ce que la parole
Dieu a créé le monde
par sa parole
la parole de Dieu
est créatrice
elle est la seule
à pouvoir créer
quelque chose
à partir de rien
Dieu a créé le monde
ex nihilo
à partir de rien
et il nous a engendré
spirituellement
ex nihilo
puisque nous étions
morts
sans vie
nous n'existions pas
spirituellement parlant
dans le bon sens du terme
c'est la parole de Dieu
qui fait surgir
l'ordre du chaos
l'existence
du néant
la vie
de la mort
seul Dieu
par sa parole
a le pouvoir
de donner la vie
de la reprendre
et de la rendre
encore une fois
selon sa pure volonté
la Bible
fait à de nombreuses reprises
le parallèle
entre la création du monde
et notre nouvelle naissance
tout simplement
parce qu'il s'agit
de deux actes
de création divine
de même nature
Dieu parle
et la vie
apparaît
la parole de Dieu
ce sont des mots
qui mis bout à bout
au fil des siècles
ont fini par former
suivant la providence
de Dieu
cet ensemble de livres
que nous appelons
la Bible
mais avant d'être
la parole
c'est d'abord
une personne
je vous laisserai relire
en entier
le premier chapitre
merveilleux
de l'évangile de Jean
où il nous dit
nous allons lire une partie
les cinq premiers versets
au commencement
était la parole
et la parole
était avec Dieu
était Dieu
elle était au commencement
avec Dieu
toutes choses ont été faites
par elle
et rien de ce qui a été fait
n'a été fait sans elle
en elle était la vie
et la vie était la lumière
des hommes
la lumière lui
dans les ténèbres
et les ténèbres
ne l'ont point reçu
et Jean poursuit plus loin
et la parole
a été faite chère
elle a habité parmi nous
pleine de grâce
et de vérité
et nous avons contemplé
sa gloire
une gloire
comme la gloire
du fils unique
venu du Père
personne n'a jamais vu Dieu
le fils unique
qui est dans le sein du Père
est celui
qui l'a fait connaître
merveilleux
passage des écritures
frères et sœurs
ce que je veux vous amener
à considérer
c'est que
notre nouvelle naissance
ne sort pas de nulle part
certes comme nous l'avons vu
elle est un acte
monergiste
qui ne dépend que de Dieu
mais sans l'incarnation
du fils unique
elle n'aurait pas été possible
il fallait que Dieu
le fils devienne
notre frère
en revêtant
la même chair
que nous
afin que Dieu
le Père
devienne
notre Père
car qu'est-ce que
cette nouvelle nature
que nous recevons de Dieu
sinon
le Christ
ressuscité
qui vit en nous
par le Saint-Esprit
quelle est cette parole
qui nous fait naître
de nouveau
sinon la bonne nouvelle
l'évangile
du Christ
qu'il a résumé en ces mots
à Nicodème
dans cette fameuse discussion
que nous avons
déjà lue en partie
voilà pourquoi
lorsque Jacques
dit que nous sommes
engendrés
par la parole
de la vérité
cela veut dire à la fois
par l'oeuvre parfaite
du fils incarné
et ensuite
par la prédication
de l'évangile
qui proclame
justement
cette oeuvre parfaite
en laquelle
nous avons foi
par le Saint-Esprit
que serait l'oeuvre
du Christ
sans prédicateur
pour annoncer
cette bonne nouvelle
au monde
un simple événement
historique
que serait l'évangile
annoncé par les prédicateurs
sans l'oeuvre
historique du Christ
un mythe
parmi les autres
la nouvelle naissance
ne peut avoir lieu
que lorsque le Saint-Esprit
convainc un homme pécheur
que l'évangile du Christ
qu'il est en train de lire
ou d'entendre
est vrai
que le fils de Dieu
la parole de vérité
s'est faite homme
en la personne
de Jésus Christ
qu'il a vécu
une vie d'obéissance
parfaite sur terre
à notre place
qu'il s'est offert
au Père
en sacrifice parfait
l'expiation
de nos péchés
sur la croix
et qu'il est ressuscité
au troisième jour
avant de monter
à la droite du Père
par la parole de vérité
veut donc dire
par Jésus Christ
qui est
la parole de vérité
et par la proclamation
de l'évangile
à notre âme
voici les deux facettes
du moyen
de notre régénération
lorsque nous naissons
de nouveau
par le Saint-Esprit
nous sommes
unis au Christ
par la foi
il vient faire
habitation en nous
et Dieu nous voit
désormais à travers
sa perfection
et il nous accepte
à nouveau
en sa présence
la beauté
de notre régénération
réside donc
aussi dans le moyen
que Dieu utilise
pour nous faire naître
de nouveau
parce que nous y voyons
chaque personne
de la Trinité
pleinement à l'œuvre
afin que notre naissance
spirituelle soit possible
de la même manière
que nous sommes émus
face à des parents
qui désirent un enfant
qui l'attendent
avec impatience
pendant neuf mois
et qui font tout
pour en prendre soin
pendant des années
ensuite
nous devrions être émus
face à Dieu le Père
le Fils et le Saint-Esprit
qui a voulu nous engendrer
qui a patienté
le temps de mettre en place
toutes les conditions
nécessaires
à cet enfantement
et qui prend soin
de nous
ses enfants
chaque jour
de notre vie
nous avons considéré
la beauté
de notre régénération
dans son origine
la seule volonté
de Dieu
dans son moyen
la proclamation
de l'évangile
du Christ incarné
crucifié
et ressuscité
il nous reste
à considérer
ce qui sera
pour nous tous
je l'espère
une grande source
d'encouragement
à persévérer
dans notre foi
jusqu'au bout
la beauté
du but
de notre régénération
Dieu nous a régénérés
comme il est dit
dans la fin
du verset 18
afin que nous fussions
comme les prémices
de ces créatures
c'est dans cette
dernière partie
que nous allons
vraiment comprendre
quel sens
ont toutes les exhortations
pratiques
de Jacques
dans sa lettre
Dieu ne nous a pas
régénérés simplement
pour que nous n'allions
pas en enfer
nous comprenons cela
en regardant
la vie du Christ
il n'a pas seulement
effacé la dette
de notre péché
en mourant
sur la croix
ce qui suffirait
pour nous éviter
l'enfer
mais il nous a aussi
crédité sa justice
en obéissant parfaitement
à son père
durant toute sa vie
sur terre
l'objectif de notre
nouvelle naissance
ce n'est pas seulement
de nous faire sortir
de l'enfer
c'est aussi de nous faire
entrer au paradis
et ce sont bien
deux choses distinctes
même si elles sont
unies en Christ
car pour ne pas aller
en enfer
il ne faut pas être
coupable
mais pour entrer
au paradis
il faut le mériter
par de bonnes oeuvres
ce sont deux choses
différentes
c'est pourquoi
Jésus
en tant que
nouvel Adam
représentant
de cette nouvelle
humanité régénérée
que nous sommes
a dû
en tant qu'homme
j'entends
mériter son entrée
et notre entrée
au paradis
en menant une vie
d'obéissance parfaite
il fallait mériter
cette entrée
au paradis
la grâce de l'évangile
c'est qu'en Jésus Christ
ces deux choses
sont les nôtres
par la foi
la dette de notre péché
est effacée
nous n'allons pas
en enfer
la justice du Christ
nous est crédité
nous entrons
au paradis
en Jésus Christ
Dieu ne s'est pas contenté
de nous éviter l'enfer
mais il a ajouté
à cela un nombre
infini de bénédictions
parmi lesquelles
notre adoption
dans sa famille
et pesons chacun
de ses mots
notre adoption
dans la famille
de Dieu
la vie éternelle
l'héritage
des nations
l'abondance
de la nouvelle création
qui viendra
la victoire
sur le péché
Satan
et les démons
et enfin
la plus grande
des bénédictions
comme Adam
le faisait
avant la chute
pouvoir à nouveau
marcher
aux côtés de Dieu
discuter avec lui
comme un fils
avec son père
la beauté
de notre régénération
se voit
par l'immense
générosité
de Dieu
à notre égard
nous qui étions
autrefois
ses ennemis
ne l'oublions pas
cette générosité
pardon
se voyait déjà
lorsque Dieu
a créé l'humanité
tout sur terre
fut créé
pour l'homme
et la femme
et assujetti
à leur autorité
seul l'être humain
fut créé
par Dieu
à son image
il était
et est toujours
dans un sens
la couronne
de la création
nous sommes déjà
en tant qu'êtres humains
les créatures
les plus dignes
les plus honorables
sur cette terre
car nous portons
l'image de Dieu
en nous
mais bien sûr
la corruption
de notre péché
masque
déforme
parfois
fait presque
disparaître
cette dignité
humaine
cette image
de Dieu
en nous
le péché
d'Adam
a entraîné
toute l'humanité
dont il était
le représentant
dans le péché
et la mort
et toute la création
pâtit des actes
de cette humanité
corrompue
qui l'a entraînée
avec elle
dans sa chute
cette création
sera jugée
nous dit la parole
elle sera détruite
avant d'être
elle aussi
régénérée
il y aura
de nouveaux cieux
et de nouvelles terres
Romain 8
nous dit que
toute la création
soupire
après sa régénération
qui doit arriver
au retour du Christ
Christ est venu sur terre
pour régénérer
sa création
qu'Adam
avait détruit
et pour la hisser
à un niveau supérieur
encore
et frères et sœurs
notre régénération
est la première étape
de cette œuvre
de restauration
complète
de la création
en tant qu'être humain
nous sommes déjà
la couronne
de la création
mais en tant que fils
et filles
adoptifs de Dieu
membres
de la nouvelle humanité
représentée par Christ
nous sommes les joyaux
de cette couronne
dont Christ
sera couronné
lors de son avènement
Dieu a décidé
de commencer
la régénération
de sa création
par nous
nous sommes
la préfiguration
du rétablissement
de toute chose
nous sommes
les ambassadeurs
du royaume des cieux
qui descendra sur terre
au dernier jour
voici en quoi
en tant qu'hommes
et femmes régénérées
nous sommes les prémices
c'est à dire
les meilleurs
des créatures
de Dieu
par le Saint-Esprit
qui nous sanctifie
en appliquant
l'œuvre du Christ
dans nos vies
par le moyen
de la parole
nous sommes transformés
de gloire en gloire
à l'image du Christ
et nous préfigurons
aux yeux des hommes
la nouvelle humanité
qui sera purifiée
une fois pour toutes
de tout péché
quel privilège
et quelle responsabilité
n'est-ce pas ?
voilà quelle est
la base fondamentale
de toute exhortation
à mettre à mort
le péché
et à obéir
à la loi de Dieu
nous ne le faisons pas
pour mériter
notre entrée
au paradis
cela a déjà été fait
par Jésus-Christ
nous obéissons
à la loi de Dieu
parce que nous siégeons
déjà en Jésus-Christ
dans les cieux
et que nous devons vivre
à la hauteur du privilège
que nous avons reçu
du Père des Lumières
de siéger
avec son Fils unique
dans les cieux
nous devons être
jour après jour
des témoignages vivants
de la nouvelle humanité
qui vivra
autour de Dieu
c'est par là
que nous comprenons
l'appel
d'être des Lumières
du sel
pour cette terre
et tout l'objectif
de la lettre de Jacques
c'est de nous donner
les outils nécessaires
pour que nous puissions
vivre en tant que témoins
en tant qu'ambassadeurs
de la nouvelle création
de Dieu
qui arrive
alors il est vrai
que face à cet appel
que Christ nous fait
de le suivre
d'être ses témoins
en gardant ses commandements
nous constatons régulièrement
nos échecs
souvent nous nous écrions
avec ou plutôt
comme l'apôtre Paul
qui me délivrera
de ce corps de mort
car nous constatons
que la parole d'ivraie
à propos de notre chair
celle-ci nous lie encore
à la corruption du péché
malheureusement
notre esprit
est bien disposé
mais notre chair
est faible
et nous désespérons
parfois de ne pas rendre
un témoignage
qui soit à la hauteur
du Christ
qui vit en nous
et que malheureusement
nous déshonorons encore
dans nos membres
en péchant
face à cela
chers assemblés
prenez courage
et ne désespérez pas
car le jour vient
où Dieu achèvera
son oeuvre
de régénération
en vous
en vous faisant
revêtir un corps
glorifié
sans souillure
incapable
de pécher
ce jour-là
nous pourrons
nous tenir
dans sa glorieuse présence
non plus en esprit seulement
comme nous le faisons
déjà aujourd'hui
mais dans notre être
tout entier
car il n'y aura plus
en nous
aucune once de ténèbres
capable de nous séparer
de Dieu
en ce jour glorieux
nous serons
parfaitement
et définitivement
les prémices
des créatures de Dieu
participant même
de sa nature
divine
lorsque toutes les
petites lumières
indépendantes
que nous sommes
rejoindront l'éclat
de la gloire
du Père des Lumières
voici
la dernière étape
de notre régénération
que nous attendons
patiemment
et avec assurance
selon les promesses
que Dieu nous a faites
à ce sujet
et frères et sœurs
dites-vous bien
que toute cette oeuvre
de régénération
que Dieu accomplit
en vous
pour vous
au-delà de servir
à la louange
de sa grâce
évidemment
a pour but
de votre bonheur
éternel
Dieu nous avait
tout donné
nous avons tout gâché
par notre péché
en nous condamnant
nous-mêmes
au malheur éternel
et il a offert
son propre fils
son fils unique
en sacrifice
pour que nous
et toute la création
à notre suite
puissions à nouveau
vivre une paix
et un bonheur parfait
en sa présence
éternellement
quel autre Dieu
dites-moi
a manifesté
autant d'amour
et de générosité
envers ces créatures
quelle autre religion
au monde
proclame un message
aussi beau
que celui
de la régénération
de l'être humain
et de toute la création
notre régénération
est belle
tout simplement
parce qu'elle est
l'oeuvre parfaite
d'un Dieu magnifique
la beauté
de la régénération
réside donc aussi
finalement
dans son but
qui est de nous rendre
entièrement
et définitivement
sains
afin que nous vivions
la vie de plénitude
parfaite
que Dieu réserve
à son peuple
dans la nouvelle création
au terme de cette prédication
je souhaite m'adresser
à deux groupes
au sein de l'auditoire
qu'ils soient dans cette salle
ou qu'ils nous suivent
à distance
à ceux qui m'écoutent
et qui n'ont pas encore
professé la foi chrétienne
prenez conscience
de deux choses
le jugement final arrive
et si vous m'entendez
en ce moment
c'est que Dieu patiente
encore jusqu'à aujourd'hui
mais aucun de nous
ne peut dire
jusqu'à quand
il va patienter
cela fait des milliers
d'années
que Dieu supporte
le péché de l'humanité
qui gangrène sa création
et qui nous avertit
encore et encore
de nous repentir
de placer notre foi
en Jésus Christ
pour être sauvé
cela fait des milliers
d'années que l'humanité
insulte Dieu
et rejette l'évangile
qui connaît le jour
de sa mort
ou celui du retour
du Christ
la seule chose
que nous savons
c'est que ce n'est pas
en ce moment
ce n'est pas
apparemment aujourd'hui
et qu'en ce dimanche
il est encore temps
de reconnaître
que l'évangile
dit vrai
Dieu est saint
vous êtes pécheurs
vos bonnes oeuvres
ne couvriront jamais
l'étendue
de vos péchés
et seul Jésus Christ
peut vous rendre pur
aux yeux de Dieu
si vous entendez
cet appel
n'endurcissez pas
votre coeur
car Dieu a voulu
que son évangile
vous soit prêché
aujourd'hui
ne restez pas indifférents
et prenez conscience
du privilège incroyable
que vous avez
de pouvoir entendre
ce message
aujourd'hui
un nombre incalculable
d'hommes et de femmes
sont morts
sans avoir
jamais entendu
l'évangile
ou alors
en étant trompés
par de fausses versions
incapables de produire
cette régénération
en eux
aujourd'hui
vous avez entendu
le vrai évangile
ne repartez pas
dans votre vie
sans avoir
pleinement considéré
les conséquences
de votre rejet
et les bénéfices
de votre repentance
Dieu nous a tant aimé
qu'il a donné
son fils unique
afin que si vous croyez
en lui
vous ne périssiez point
mais que vous ayez
la vie éternelle
alors si vous êtes
dans cette salle
ne partez pas
sans venir me voir
pour que nous puissions
parler et prier ensemble
si vous nous suivez en ligne
écrivez-nous un message
sur notre site internet
sur la page facebook
de l'église
que le Saint-Esprit
puisse vous convaincre
de la vérité
sauvez votre âme
en ce jour
et frères et sœurs
pour vous qui connaissez
déjà ces vérités
je prie
comme je vous le partageais
en introduction
que le Saint-Esprit
ravive vos affections
envers ce don parfait
de la régénération
que Dieu nous a accordé
que votre reconnaissance
et votre amour pour Dieu
en soient décuplés
et que par là
votre adoration
soit plus vive
et chaleureuse
votre obéissance
plus ailée
et plus constante
apprenons à considérer
toutes les grâces
que Dieu nous accorde
comme excellentes
et en particulier
ce don parfait
de notre régénération
quel amour
quelle générosité
quel sacrifice
Dieu a manifesté
à chaque étape
nécessaire
de notre nouvelle naissance
tout cela
pour que nous rebelles
soyons réconciliés
avec lui
pour que nous
enfants indignes
puissions revenir
dans sa maison
pour que nous
perdus dans notre idolâtrie
puissions à nouveau
lui rendre
un vrai culte
en esprit
et en vérité
prenons le temps
de méditer
sur toutes les facettes
de notre régénération
et ne cessons jamais
d'en contempler
la beauté
qui n'est autre
que celle de Dieu
lui-même
et ne perdons jamais
de vue
le but glorieux
de notre nouvelle naissance
nous sommes les prémices
de la nouvelle création
qui arrive
que le Saint-Esprit
nous fortifie
qu'il nous rende capables
de mener des vies
qui témoignent puissamment
de cette nouvelle identité
céleste
que nous avons reçu
du Père des Lumières
menons des vies
qui interpellent
et attirent
les païens
vers cette nouvelle création
qui arrive
manifestons l'amour
que nous avons
pour notre Père Céleste
en gardant
ses commandements
dans la continuité
de cette prédication
nous allons passer
à la Sainte Seine
le repas du Seigneur
que nous allons partager
maintenant
joue un grand rôle
dans nos vies
pour ce que nous venons
de méditer ensemble
pour la persévérance
dans notre foi
la Sainte Seine
est un des deux sacrements
que le Christ
a donné à son Église
c'est un repas
qui est réservé
au peuple de Dieu
qui est très important
pour notre foi
car non seulement
par le pain et le vin
nous nous remémorons
ce que Christ
nous a acquis
à un moment
dans l'histoire
par sa mort à la croix
mais par ce sacrement
dans lequel Jésus
est présent avec nous
en esprit
il raffermit notre assurance
de son pardon
et de notre justification
en lui
devant Dieu
c'est un repas
qui est donc réservé
à tous ceux
qui se sont repentis
de leur péché
qui ont placé leur foi
en Jésus Christ
seul
pour leur salut
et qui ont rendu
de cela
un témoignage public
dans une église locale
dans laquelle
ils ont été baptisés
suite à leur profession
de foi
selon les convictions
baptistes
de notre église
ce n'est pas un repas
pour des hommes
et des femmes parfaits
comme nous venons
de le voir
aucun de nous
ne le sera
avant le retour du Christ
et qu'il nous revête
de ce nouveau corps
incorruptible
c'est justement
un repas
pour ceux qui reconnaissent
qu'ils sont plus
qu'imparfaits
et qu'ils ont besoin
du Christ en eux
pour être déclarés justes
et progressivement
rendus justes
par le Saint-Esprit
jusqu'au jour
de notre glorification
si donc vous êtes
en bonne santé spirituelle
en ce moment
remerciez Dieu
pour cela
prenez ces éléments
en priant
pour que le Saint-Esprit
vous maintienne
dans le bon témoignage
que vous rendez
en ce moment
et si au contraire
vous sentez
que vous n'allez pas bien
spirituellement
que vous avez
offensé Dieu
par votre péché
mais que vous êtes repentant
que vous êtes déterminé
à faire tous vos efforts
pour vivre
une vie de sainteté
alors prenez aussi
ces éléments
en priant
pour qu'à travers eux
le Christ vous fortifie
dans l'assurance
de votre salut
et surtout
dans votre détermination
à vivre
une vie de sainteté
seuls ceux
qui n'ont pas professé
publiquement leur foi
qui ne sont pas baptisés
selon
les convictions baptistes
après leur profession de foi
et s'obstinent
ou s'obstinent
pardon
intentionnellement
dans le péché
qu'ils soient privés
ou publics
sont interdits
de participer
à la Sainte Seine
pour le bien de l'Église
et pour leur propre bien
comme nous allons le lire
en 1 Corinthien
chapitre 11
avant de lire ce passage
j'invite donc
ceux qui vont participer
à la Sainte Seine
à venir chercher
les éléments
à la table
puis nous lirons
1 Corinthien 1
verset 23 à 30
nous prierons ensemble
et nous partagerons
la Sainte Seine
à la Sainte Seine
à la Sainte
!
à la Sainte Seine